wir sprechen über den
gesundheitsminister und ordentlich
verwirrung um die korona regeln wieder
einmal muss man leider sagen hier sehen
sie die seite 2 heute von bild die
verwirrungen auch vom
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach geht
sie diesmal aus ja wer genau weiß ich
jetzt noch mal impfen lassen oder vor
allen dingen auch ja gut auf womit nun
mit welchem impfstoff auch das nicht
klar und soll man sich künftig wirklich
alle drei monate impfen lassen kann doch
gar nicht sein am abend hat der minister
versucht wer bin ich ein bisschen
klarheit in die auch selbst gestiftete
verwirrung oder umgekehrt her indem er
sich vom krankenbett aus zu wort
gemeldet hat
der gesundheitsminister krank immer noch
corona geschwächt und doch gibt er
interviews mir geht es wieder besser
obwohl ich sagen muss also dass ich war
die symptome
regieren vom krankenbett die eigene
politik erklären das muss lauterbach
denn er hat neue corona verwirrung
gestiftet mit der 3 monats im frieden
nur wer frisch geimpft ist darf noch
ohne maske oder ohne tests in
restaurants oder kinos gehen soll man
sich jetzt etwa alle drei monate impfen
lassen also ich glaube es wird
momente die verwirrung stiften wollen
zum beispiel ich habe nie gesagt dass
alle jüngeren leute sich jetzt impfen
lassen sondern das ist einfach falsch
das wird immer wieder unterstellt das
ist aber nicht richtig das habe ich nie
gesagt und so ist es auch doch das hat
lauterbach eben doch gesagt beim spiegel
am 14 juli ich selbst würde es wie folgt
macht also wenn jemand den sommer
genießen und will kein risiko gehen
beispielsweise zu erkranken vielleicht
auch länger zu erkranken oder anlagen
sowie zu erkranken dann würde ich in
absprache natürlich mit dem hausarzt
würde ich auch jüngeren die impfung
empfehlen die stiko empfiehlt ja jetzt
nur sagen beim allgemeinen aber die
umwelt schaden ist ja immer eine
entscheidung zwischen hausarzt und dem
betroffenen also was geht denn nun
nein ich habe nicht gesagt für alle die
vierten punkt nur darauf hingewiesen
dass wir auch eine botschaft für die
unter 60-jährigen oder die unter
70-jährigen benötigt man zum beispiel
soll eine solche impfung dann
stattfinden in absprache mit dem arzt
oder also wovon hängt das ab zum
beispiel jemand der ganz besonders viele
kontakte hat die man zum beispiel der
krank ist und somit viele risiken und
noch eine frage herr lauterbach wie soll
man künftig erkennen im restaurant wer
frisch geimpft ist kriegt er einen
stempel
geplant ist dass auf der krone war nicht
einfach das zertifikat so lange wie die
drei monate noch nicht um es in eine
andere farbe hat somit also dass noten
normale ebenfalls ja blau erscheint
wurde dann ist ja weise in grün
erscheinen so dass beim reingehen jeder
sofort ziehen das ist ein frisches
kapital
und jetzt rein in den ukraine krieg der
seit einem halben jahr mittlerweile
läuft und diese bilder hier die zeigen
eine überraschende wendung in diesem
ukraine krieg nach einem halben jahr die
ukrainische armee sie greift offenbar
russische stellung auf der krim an eine
gegenattacke also auf dem gebiet das
sich putin 2014 unter den nagel gerissen
hat
schwere explosionen auf der von russland
besetzten halbinsel krim die videos die
seit dienstagnachmittag in den sozialen
medien kursieren bezeugen einen
strategischen wechsel der ukrainischen
militäroperationen
offenbar macht die ukraine ernst greift
nun auch von putins armee und seinen
handlangern besetzte gebiete in größerer
entfernung an die explosionen auf der
russischen luftwaffenbasis in der nähe
der stadt nur wofür durica reißen die
menschen aus einer trügerischen stille
tragen das kriegsgeschehen jetzt auch
vor ihrer haustür
[Musik]
ich mein badezimmer und hörte
unfassbaren leer ich hatte das gefühl
dass etwas großes heruntergefallen war
an lief ich zum fenster uns heraus es
sah so aus als ob ein atompilz von einer
atomexplosion dort aufgestiegen wäre es
gab zwei große explosionen wie diese an
stürzte alles ein
[Musik]
nach offiziellen angaben von russischer
seite stirbt ein mensch umgehend wird
behauptet auf dem flugplatz seine
munitionslager explodiert tatsächlich
ist davon auszugehen dass die ukraine
die luftwaffenbasis der russen mit
hochmodernen raketen aus den beständen
seiner westlichen unterstützer
angegriffen hat liebe ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer heute richtet sich viel
aufmerksamkeit auf die krim und das zu
recht wenn die creme des ukrainischen
und werden sie niemals verleugnen wir
werden nicht vergessen dass der
russische krieg gegen die ukraine mit
der besetzung der krim begann dieser
russische krieg gegen die ukraine und
gegen das ganze freie europa hat auf der
krim begonnen und muss auf der krim
enden durch ihre befreiung es wäre der
erste angriff der ukrainischen armee auf
die von russland besetzte halbinsel krim
und das nicht seit dem beginn von putins
blutigen krieg gegen die ukraine im
februar 2022 sondern seit märz 2014 im
start der russischen besatzung
[Musik]
bild-reporter björn stritzel jetzt aus
der ukraine und zugeschaltet hier gerade
in dem moment reißt die schalter ab nein
da bist du gehören ich grüße dich
herzlich in die ukraine dort in den
osten des landes die entscheidende frage
russisches militär
gebiet dort getroffen durch ukrainische
raketen oder ein unfall auf der
russischen seite dort auf der krim
welche hinweise hast du was kannst du
tun um aufzuklären
also die die propaganda des russischen
teams das sich dabei wieder um einen
unfall gehandelt hat so wie es auch so
schon in den vergangenen fünf spontanen
munitions entzündungen unfälle gehandelt
haben soll wie halte ich dafür nicht
sehr glaubwürdig das ist eine
wahrscheinlich der wichtigste
luftwaffenstützpunkt den die großen
errichtet haben auf den besitzern
ukrainische territorium von dort aus
werden die antworten der ukraine
geflogen unter anderem in der nähe des
besetzten fassungen in der südlich vom
publisher insofern das wird einfach sich
mehrere munitionslager spontane
selbstentzündung halte ich für sehr
unwahrscheinlich
hat die welt an den rand und bereit zu
schießen und so weit zu treffen
also nach nach offiziellen angaben nicht
sie haben sie haben in der eigenen
entwicklung einer ballistischen rakete
die sich ja noch keine tests absolviert
hat sie haben hier seht ihr flugkörper
die neptun beziehungsweise auch die
behauptung die das theoretisch auch
erreichen könnten mit mit irland
finnland ziele angreifen könnten sie
haben aber mutmaßlich auch mittlerweile
munition für heime systeme
beziehungsweise für die mls die die bis
zu 300 kilometer weit ziele angreifen
könnten das bisher noch nicht offiziell
bestätigt dass über diese mit diese
munition auch verfügen aber das
erscheint mir als signalgeber werden
jetzt hat uns das ja alle überrascht
alle experten waren überrascht dass
dieser offenbare ukrainische angriff
dort auf der krim passiert ist das so
etwas wie eine jahr völlig überraschende
wendung in diesem ukraine krieg nach
einem halben jahr oder ist das eine
einmalige schlag und da steckt im grunde
jetzt nicht mehr dahinter das läuft in
richtung rückeroberung der krim
also ich komme von der rückeroberung der
krim zu sprechen das ist natürlich ein
strategisches ziel und das ist sozusagen
das was willst du ja auch skizziert hat
aber das ist nicht das jetzt unmittelbar
ansteht allerdings ist es natürlich ein
nach einem halben jahr hat russland die
sich ja selbst für die zweitgrößte zwei
schlagkräftigste armee der welt halten
es immer noch nicht geschafft die
lufthoheit über der ukraine zu
erhalten und haben auch jetzt sozusagen
damit zu kämpfen dass ihre eigenen basen
mehr als 200 kilometer entfernt von der
front attackiert werden mit mutmaßlich
ballistischen raketen mit ja oder
beziehungsweise mit anderen waffen von
denen wir noch nichts wissen insofern
das ist natürlich jagdverbände
vielleicht so sprecher ein bisschen zu
früh aber es zeigt natürlich dass dieser
russische angriffskrieg alles andere als
dem entspricht was was moskau
ursprünglich geplant hat mit dieser mit
dieser angeblichen 72 stunden operation
danke für deine analyse bild-reporter
bier und schnitzel aus der ukraine für
bild live via der der einst der chef von
tengelmann war er ist verschollen karl
erivan haub seit dem siebten april 2018
also mehr als vier jahren fehlt jede
spur von ihm seit einer bergtour längst
ist er für tot erklärt worden das ist
ein krimi diese geschichte um diesen
tengelmann boss und dieser krimi um den
tengelmann milliardär der geht noch
weiter denn vor wenigen tagen hat jetzt
ein bergsteiger ein skelett gefunden in
der matterhorn region dort wo haupt
dieser tengelmann milliardär bergsteigen
war genau dort ist das was man dort
gefunden hat dass tengelmann skelett wir
warten auf antwort auf diese frage und
sprechen darüber mit unser bild reporter
jörg völkerling der sich auf die spuren
gemacht hat den vergangenen tagen mal
wieder auf die spuren des tengelmann
milliardärs karl erivan haub welche
hinweise jörg schon guten morgen gibt es
darauf dass das dass tengelmann skelett
ist
die antwort darauf liegt hinter mir in
der morgensonne verbogen dort steht das
matterhorn und karl erivan haub hatte ja
an dem morgen mit skiausrüstung den weg
auf das kleine matterhorn beginn gemacht
wir können das hier nachvollziehen an
der karte er ist zur höchst gelegenen
bergstation
europas gefahren und von dort aus hatte
er mehrere möglichkeiten sozusagen wege
pisten zu nehmen und seine die leiche
die man jetzt gefunden hat lag am stock
die gletscher das ist tatsächlich auch
eine option dass er diesen weg genommen
hat deswegen ist die fantasie natürlich
angesprungen in den letzten tagen dass
es sich bei dieser offenbar recht gut
erhaltenen leiche um karl erivan haub
handelt sie liegt im moment noch in der
gerichtsmedizin und ziehen es gibt noch
keine endgültige identifizierung das
dauert ein bisschen die dna muss
verglichen werden es gibt allerdings ein
paar hinweise die sagen naja ob es
wirklich karl erivan haub war er hat
eine skiausrüstung aus den 70er jahren
dabei war hat eine jeans an all das ist
jetzt nicht unbedingt etwas was so einen
sportler wie karl erivan haub der die
partie die glacis mehrere male
mitgemacht hat wirklich angezogen hätte
also das war du sagst ein ganz
erfahrener ein ganz sportlicher
bergsteiger was macht man da jetzt noch
weiter um das herauszufinden klar die
enertec hast du gesagt dabei gibt es
auch weitere sucharbeiten dort am
matterhorn um vielleicht noch weitere
indizien weitere hinweise zu finden
ich habe gestern mit dem chef der
bergrettung an land rover gesprochen der
damals auch die rettungsmaßnahme
suchmaßnahmen
koordiniert hat und der hat ja die
leiche sozusagen geborgen die war in
einem stück die war gut erhalten
mumifiziert
suchaktionen jetzt finden in dem bereich
nicht statt allerdings in den letzten
tagen sind wieder knochen gefunden
wurden in saas fee in einem anderen
gletscher das hat natürlich mit dem
klimawandel zu tun die nullgradgrenze es
hier auf über 5000 meter gestiegen die
sommersaison wo sonst immer hier auch im
sommer gefahren werden konnte musste
abgesagt werden also da kommen natürlich
jetzt einige sachen ans licht vielleicht
lichtet sich auf die weise auch das
geheimnis um karriere um dienst ja doch
noch ganz andere spekulationen gibt um
sein verschwinden ja du sagst es spricht
noch mal ein paar von diesen
verschwörungstheorien auch an dass er ja
tatsächlich ein krimi und eine ganz
besondere geschichte dieser ja einer der
reichsten männer deutschlands
verschwindet plötzlich spurlos also
natürlich auch immer wieder die
geschichte der ist einfach abgetaucht er
hat sich neues leben gesucht
ja die familie haub ist natürlich eine
der reichsten familien deutschlands über
vier milliarden beträgt ihr vermögen und
die zeit in der karl erivan haub
verschwand eine sehr bewegte zeit es gab
auseinandersetzungen in diesen familien
clan der vater von karl erivan haub war
einen monat vorher verstorben es ging
natürlich um das aufteilen des erbes und
ich habe selber mit jemand aus seinem
trainings starb gesprochen damals ich
war ja mit dem kollegen sascha baumann
hier schonmal 2018 auf spurensuche und
derjenige sagte mir eigentlich karrieren
haupt wäre niemals einfach so auf gerade
wohl an einem solchen morgen alleine
aufgebrochen um da noch mal einfach
trainieren zu gehen also es war die
möglichkeit die relativ frühen spiel kam
dass er über italien nach hinten
sozusagen wie sind die hier auf der
schweizer seite einfach ins tal hinab
gefahren ist und da irgendwo sich in
luft aufgelöst hat verschwunden hat
irgendwo ein neues leben begonnen hat
und da kam natürlich dann zum beispiel
auch eine russin spiel eine
mitarbeiterin einer modelagentur und
sankt petersburg zu der offenbar
beziehungen hatte welcher art auch immer
also steht die frage im raum warum dann
auch so schnell eine todeserklärung von
der familie angestrebt wurde die schon
drei jahre danach vom amtsgericht köln
erklärt wurde also da ist vieles was
einfach noch im nebel liegt so wie das
matterhorn hier an diesem morgen und
möglicherweise verzieht sich ein
bisschen von diesem nebel in den
nächsten stunden wenn dann die dna dort
gecheckt ist und wir wissen ist es das
tengelmann skeletten oder ist es das
nicht danke an unser bild reporter jörg
völkerling dort an den fuß des
matterhorns tolle bilder hinter dir das
bild live schönen guten morgen an diesem
mittwoch der mit der traurigen
gewissheit beginnt der in bayern so
verzweifelt gesuchte tobias ist tot wir
waren noch mit der hoffnung ins bett
gegangen dass er lebend gefunden wird
mithilfe all seine freunde die einfach
nicht glauben konnten dass es seitdem
gemeinsam feiern am freitag keine spur
mehr von ihm gibt mit hilfe der polizei
die eine riesige suchaktion gestartet
hatte aber tobias lebt nicht mehr
so jung erst 25 jahre alt und plötzlich
tot tobias aus dem bayerischen eching
der fröhliche gut aussehender junger
mann mit lederhose verschwunden seit
freitag seine engsten freunde sie haben
verzweifelt nach ihnen gesucht nicht
gefunden wir treffen uns heute wieder
zum suchen brauchen natürlich so viel
hilfe wie möglich doch es gibt keine
spur die tage vergehen ohne hinweise auf
tobias sein letztes lebenszeichen beim
brass wiesen festival am echinger see im
landkreis freising
gemeinsames feiern gemeinsames trinken
dann zieht ein schweres gewitter auf das
festival wird aus sicherheitsgründen
abgebrochen tausende machen sich schnell
gleichzeitig auf den heimweg tobias
freunde verlieren ihnen der anger aus
den augen wenig später bricht auch der
telefonische kontakt zu ihm ab ab 22.30
ist sein handy aus er wird noch einmal
gesehen am eingang zum campingplatz
stark betrunken mit schürfwunden an den
abend so heißt das dann nichts mehr die
polizei ermittelt eine große suche läuft
an hubschrauber wasserwacht feuerwehr
und rettungshundestaffel doch von tobias
fehlt jede spur bis dienstagabend dann
die traurige gewissheit tobias ist tot
seine leiche wird von einem schwimmer im
echinger see gefunden
und wir sprechen mit kalk heim der diese
suche nach tobias in den vergangenen
tagen so eng begleitet hat unser bild
reporter größe dich karl diese nachricht
die bricht jetzt das herz erst recht
nachdem wir all die freunde von tobias
ja gesehen haben die so verzweifelt
gesucht haben in den letzten tagen hier
muss eine welt zusammengebrochen seien
ja du sagst es kein mann hatte es
mitbekommen das ist in sozialen
netzwerken durch ganz deutschland
gegangen wurde vielfach geteilt
millionenfach geteilt diese aufrufe auch
freunde und bekannte von mir haben das
geteilt bei instagram oder auch bei
facebook ja und jetzt ja diese treuen
gewissheit dass er tot ist
da gibt es irgendwelche hinweise wie
tobias ums leben gekommen es gibt es
hinweise auf ein gewaltverbrechen
nach dem derzeitigen stand gibt es daher
keine hinweise dass es sich um ein
gewaltverbrechen um sogenanntes
fremdverschulden handelt man geht die
polizei geht von einem klassischen
unfall aus er war er stark alkoholisiert
hatte er noch mal dagegen kurz vor 23
uhr sich ein neues bier gekauft soll
nach zeugenaussagen auch tatsächlich sie
ist gerade eben noch so auf den beinen
halten können und dann tatsächlich
verliert sich die spur man hat die groß
abgesucht alles interessanterweise ist
hier auch über diesen echinger see wo er
dann hinter mir gefunden wurde auch am
montag einer der acht
polizeihubschrauber drüber geflogen der
hatte hier allerdings nichts entdeckt
und erst gestern abend der so gegen 18
45 hat ein schwimmer diese grausame
entdeckung gemacht dass hier plötzlich
eine männliche leiche im auf der
wasseroberfläche schwimmt und dann hat
man relativ zügig feststellen können
dass es sich um tobias handelt die
kleidung das aussieht und auch
persönliche gegenstände passten dazu ich
gehe davon aus dass die
staatsanwaltschaft landshut eine
obduktion anordnen wird um auch ganz
sicher ausschließen zu können dass sie
sich nicht doch um ein
fremdverschulden handelt aber nach dem
jetzigen nach dem jetzigen stand geht
man hier von einem tragischen unfall aus
der fall war so seltsam weil man ja
gemeinsam gefeiert hatte und dann sich
jede spur von diesem 25 jährigen
plötzlich verlor und dieser fall war
auch so besonders weil eben die freunde
so intensiv gesucht haben und so
emotionale videos gepostet haben eine
eigene anlaufstelle gegründet haben für
hinweise was hörst du dort aus dem
umfeld jetzt von tobias kann
also bisher hat man sich aus dem umfeld
noch nicht geäußert der die familie die
freunde werden von einem
kriseninterventionsteam betreut das ist
natürlich auch ein riesengroßer schock
man hat zuletzt gehofft bis zuletzt
gehofft dass man ihn neben finden wird
ja diese hoffnung die schwindende dann
immer mit je länger das dann halt
gedauert hat das hat auch die polizei
gesagt je länger das dauert desto
geringer ist die chance im leben zu
finden
es bleibt abzuwarten wie jetzt ob es
dann noch mal ein statement geben wir
weil es waren tatsächlich sehr sehr
viele freunde bekannte oder auch einfach
nur leute die das bei bild gesehen haben
oder bei anderen medien oder diese
aufrufe die einfach mitzuhelfen die
ihnen gar nicht kannten die dann 40
gestern am see aufgetaucht sind sohn
gesagt haben menschen wollen hier
einfach mit helfen wir wollen wir helfen
tobias leben zu finden ja jetzt diese
selben schreckliche gewissheit dass
diese hilfe ja nichts gebracht hat danke
karl heim unser bild reporter dort in
eching am echinger see wo man eben jetzt
die leiche vom 25 jahre alten tobias
gefunden hat die traurige gewissheit
unsere gedanken sind heute mit der
familie von tobias und als gäb's nicht
genügend steuern basteln einige
umweltexperten jetzt schon an der neuen
steuer und das ist es wäre es zu sagen
kein witz sie basteln an einer steuer
für kühe genauer gesagt nach kurths
steuer für
grüne wiesen kleine kälber grasende kühe
sieht gar nicht nach umwelt bedrohung
aus doch kein anderes nutztier verdaut
so klimaschädlich wie die kuh so heißt
es und ihr putzen könnte ganz schön
teuer werden über den pansen generiert
das nutztier methan das ist die
klimaschädliche variante von co2 alle
drei minuten rutscht der kuh einer raus
[Musik]
bis zu 100 gramm methan kann eine
einzelne kuh im jahr ausblasen
deshalb liebäugelt der chef des
umweltbundesamtes dirk messner mit einer
co2 steuer für kühe weil die halt so
viel putzen das wäre sie dann die
vorsteuer der verbandschef
familienbetriebe land und forst ev max
freiherr von elverfeldt lässt daraufhin
erstmal ganz schön dampf ab wer das
putzen und rückten von kühen mit einer
klimasteuer belegen will der besteuert
das leben selbst und wo soll dieser
klimawandel enden was kommt dann als
nächstes auf den tisch eine geruch
steuer für volle babywindeln oder eine
allgemeine steuerpflicht für verbrauchte
atemluft zumal es gelungen von türen ja
auch noch andere lösungen gibt einen
schicken club sac zum beispiel
so machen es die argentinischen bauern
vor auch das umweltbundesamt findet die
idee von seinem chef nicht so durfte um
die landwirtschaft klima und
umweltfreundlicher zu gestalten braucht
es einen mix aus verschiedenen maßnahmen
eine co2 abgabe auf kinder empfiehlt das
umweltbundesamt jedoch gegenwärtig nicht
immerhin sind auch nur drei prozent der
gesamtdeutschen methan emissionen auf
die kuh selber zurückzuführen der
verkehr kommt auf knapp 20 prozent also
eine kuh ist kein auto am ende
vielleicht also doch nur alles heiße
luft
darüber sprechen wir jetzt verbunden
sind wir mit max von elverfeldt
vorsitzender der familienbetriebe land
und forst schön dass sie hier bei uns
sind ja wenn wir jetzt die kuh
beziehungsweise den furz von der kuh
besteuern so was für das was ging ihnen
durch den kopf zitiert von diesem
vorschlag gehört haben ja also völliger
irrsinn was dort diskutiert werde zeigen
einfach wie ideologisch die klimapolitik
und wenig praxistauglich thema politik
diskutiert wird jetzt an der ku steuer
ist aber sehr plastisch gezeigt worden
wo kommen wir da hin dann fangen wir
irgendwann an dass wir den fuchs unserer
kinder bestehen müssen also zeigt
einfach wie wenig ebens tauglich solche
gedanken sind ich bin hier extra schnell
waren als ich bin erfahren haben was wir
wollten und so gemobbt werden sie gleich
mal abgehauen
das glaube ich ihnen alles andere
allerdings schon das umweltbundesamt hat
ja die kuh dann erst mal so ein bisschen
doch vom eis geholt und hat gesagt na
kuh steuer vielleicht doch nicht aber
wie wäre es denn wenn wir alle weniger
kühe hätten also haben sie haben wir
alle in deutschland so viele kühe
also man muss immer gucken wir um das
ganze auf zieht natürlich grundsätzlich
stimmt natürlich sie haben sie einen
bericht gesagt klar
die tiere natürlich getan und co2 aber
die frage wie regeln wäre das das kann
ja nicht dadurch gehen indem wir hier
die produktion einschränken das prüfen
zumal die arbeitsplätze viele dieser
aufgaben
sie müssen dann teurer machen das hat
die entsprechende auswirkung daneben an
der kasse im supermarkt der käse butter
und milch teurer werden wir haben gerade
erfahren in england fangen sie jetzt
damit anwalt diese preise so stark
gestiegen es darf dort schon
diebstahlsicher und daran hängt weil sie
sorgen haben dass käse geklaut wird also
die gefahr dass dort eben die preise
gewaltig steigen
zeigt ein kunde wie er sie nicht das ist
aber grundsätzlich stimmt das natürlich
und die frage ist niemand das thema eben
angeht und wir können wir eben nicht
über die produktion seite brauchen wir
müssen bei den nachfrage bei den
konsumenten dort müssen wir
sensibilisierung hinbringen tatsächlich
einfach weniger fleischprodukte
milchprodukte zu konsumieren dann wird
auch weniger produziert und erzeugt und
dann kommen wir auch zu ziel aber man
muss eben aufpassen die roma dass
der nächste punkt ist ja auch dass wir
lagerungs effekte befürchten müssen
aktuell ist es so dass wir in
deutschland hat sich eine kleine
überproduktion haben wir 110 111 prozent
der milch wer in deutschland brauchen
werden auch in deutschland produziert
also wir können elf exportieren wenn wir
jetzt einfach sagen wir reduzieren ich
sag mal was um 20 prozent und der konsum
geht nicht gleichzeitig runter dann
müssen wir milch ja importieren aus
anderen ländern und pupsen da die kühe
noch nichts gewonnen ja das stimmt dann
ist nur unsere weste sozusagen ein
bisschen bisschen weißer hierher
deutschland aber mich interessiert wir
gucken ja überall nach
emissionseinsparungen das emissionsfreie
autos die emissionsfreie heizung gibt
sie auch die emissionsarme kuh
gibt es natürlich am ende nicht weil sie
natürlich einfach methan und co2 aus
buchs ist nun holt so gedacht der chef
des bundes umwelt haben natürlich recht
also da gibt's keine art von trudi
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger und ein
bisschen emissions-
günstiger ist bisschen feingefühl ist
natürlich deshalb bin ich auch mit ihm
hier auf die weide gegangen und sie
haben das ja auch in ihrer anmoderation
gezeigt wie kühe auf der weide das sind
sogar wahre klimaschützer weil ja das
gas auf den grünflächen fressen und
gleichzeitig ihre verdauung auf der
wiese lassen und das fördert die im co2
im humus im boden und bin dadurch co2 in
den böden und dort wird mehr gebunden
als die cqm pupsen wieder raus lässt
insofern ist die beibehaltung auf jeden
fall eine co2 positive die halten also
kommen kuh und klima ja doch irgendwie
zusammen und wir können sogar ableiten
es gibt ja einen verdauungs mechanismen
der kühe sogar auch noch positiver
fällt vielen herzlichen dank für das
gespräch mit einer für ihre zeit
[Musik]